[Music]
medicine
is an intensely practical subject you're
always
trying to decide what to do to people
and it's traditionally been taught
as a hands-on subject as an
apprenticeship
you follow the practitioner around and
see what the practitioner is doing
so it's hard to see so clinical practice
traditionally was an apprenticeship
and the practitioner told you what they
were doing
and why they were doing it and you
learnt
on the job and what they would also do
as they were doing it is explain
why they were doing the things they did
in terms of
their beliefs about what we've now
called science their beliefs about how
the world works
so if they believed in the four humors
they would talk about
balancing these humors in people if they
believed in astrology they would talk
about the influence of the stars
there were all kinds of different ideas
about medicine
and the practitioner would tell you what
their views were
and explain why they were doing what
they were doing
to that particular patient so they would
describe
the case in terms of the
beliefs they had about the world because
the idea
of medical practice was to change the
state
of the patient and make the patient
better
now of course everybody knows that if
you
get the science wrong or if the science
is incomplete
what you do to your patient may not be
what you think you're doing to your
patient
and it may make the patient work or it
may work or it may have nothing to do
with the patient
now here are some little pictures that i
wouldn't have bothered with for you but
come from
another undergraduate course there is
the first emperor of china
his he wanted to become immortal and so
his doctors gave him mercury to try to
make him immortal
because it was full of life um that is
somebody during the plague in the middle
ages
and they thought the plague was caused
by the wrath of god
as some people recently think the floods
were caused by the wrath of god
um so they went around whipping
themselves
as penance to try to put a stop to the
plague
it wasn't the medical practitioners
exactly but for all we know the medical
practitioners might have done that
that's carlos the bewitched of spain
who had this genetic deformation of the
jaw
which ran in the whole of his family
they didn't know why they thought he'd
had a spell put on him so they hunted
for witches in the streets
um we can now trace the family tree
with the gene that caused this marie
antoinette had a mild version of it as
well
so the things they did were absolutely
useless
but people will go for any kind of cure
they think they can find
which is why so many of the more
doubtful fringe medicines
have so many followers these days anyway
medicine gradually did more and more
scientific research
and it knew it had to do inquiry
knew it had to push itself forward and
this went on
in science for a long time especially
with advances in the 19th century
and then we have the extraordinary fact
recently
relatively recently that medicine
started talking about
evidence-based medicine most of the swan
medics thought it was based on evidence
all the time
but now they're concerned with medicine
based evidence
and they now tell the students that
they've got to keep up to date with
scientific reasoning and they've got to
go
keep going back to conferences and
things to learn these things
so everybody knows that you've got to
get your facts as right as possible
and we're pushing further and further
and finding things
all the time and of course we want to
find things all the time because that's
where
cures lie that's how we can improve
things
but at the same time this is exactly
what has got medicine
out of its depth it doesn't know where
it is with all the powers it's got
and this is what i'll try to show now
the trouble with knowing an awful lot of
facts
and knowing how to manipulate the world
is that what you know is a series of
this is
true therefore if i do this this will
happen
so it's about how you influence things
but on the other hand knowledge is
completely
neutral you can do anything you like
with it
once you've got it knowledge is power
but it's power for doing anything you
want
and we have some dreadful stories in the
history of medicine
here is our friend mr shipman dr shipman
who used his knowledge to
not exactly lure in old ladies and kill
them but it was that sort of thing he
was busy
do you recognize him yeah yeah he's
mengele
and there's auschwitz and he was a
trained doctor he had exactly the same
training as other doctors
but he decided to put it to a different
use
so obviously it's not enough for
medicine
to know an awful lot of facts and to
find out more
there's obviously a lot of question
about what you do with those facts
now some people say it's obvious you
just have to do good the thing that
makes a
doctor a doctor is not just
knowledge of the skills but doing the
right things
with it so a lot of people will say well
it's just a matter of doing no harm
or it's just a matter of following the
hippocratic oath
um has any of you've ever read the
hippographic both
the original one
it's fascinating but what happens what
happened
was if you're going to present yourself
as an
expert to the public you want to say
not only what skills you've got but
something about what
uses your group puts those skills
and hippocrates is not have were a
sort of sect medical sect and they had
all kinds of aspects of their oath one
of them interestingly was that they
wouldn't tread on the territory of these
surgeons
and they also said they would love their
teachers and respect them as if they
were their own parents and
all sorts of trade secrets and things
so the point is that when you get a
certain amount of knowledge
you may get together with other people
and put out
what modern companies would call their
ethical codes
their standards of how they would behave
but of course they weren't
all necessarily the same at all
what you did was put out reassurances to
your patients
so people would be told that this was
the kind of use you would put your
knowledge to
and the hippocratics among other things
said they would not
divulge their patients secrets
so it's um that's very much more than
confidentiality that's one thing that
has survived now the point is
every single time you make a decision
about
practice about doing things
there are necessarily values involved
you're not simply using your knowledge
you're
making decisions about what use you're
going to put your knowledge
and values can come in various kinds
they can be
completely selfish values
so shipments values i don't know do you
get a kick out of killing these people
i don't know we don't know because he
hanged himself before we found out
but there could be all kinds of
values that people have and a lot of
doctors
are accused by largely rival doctors but
other people as well
of working in their own interests for
instance one of the subjects we're going
to be discussing is
transplants and a lot of the transplant
surgeons
accuse the nephrologists of keeping
people on dialysis
instead of referring them to transplants
because they make a lot of money out of
dialysis so you get accusations like
that doctors may say
ah job is to help people but you never
know
doctors are human so they may be going
by
their own selfish values they may be
going by moral values in the very broad
sense now the broader
sense of moral values is values which
you
use if you're morally conscientious to
control your own actions against
your own best interests if that's
what um if the two of them conflict
and also the interesting thing about
humans as moral animals
is that we will often sacrifice our own
interests
to make other people conform to our
moral values
there seems to be a deep streak of
altruism in human nature
so that even if it costs us something to
bring a wrongdoer to justice
we're willing to do it it seems to be
part of our social
nature this is increasingly being
established by
moral psychologists and evolutionary
psychologists
but the point is so it isn't just a
conflict between moral
and selfish you've also got the
conflicts between all kinds of different
moral values the moral values are the
ones you're going to have to put out to
your patients
it's no good telling your patients
you're going to work in your own
self-interest
but you might have different moral
values that you're putting out to your
patients
and a very striking one now is that
some doctors are happy to perform
abortions and some won't do it
any parents because they have different
moral
views that's not obviously self-interest
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas